well the title is so nice you do it once
you want to do it twice
and it has happened here maxine
congratulations on guaranteeing yourself
at least a tie for the singfield cup it
must feel really sweet to accomplish
this uh it is especially as i had a
tough year in general
i've been putting my playback together
basically since july and my
my play my results have improved and
yeah here's the culmination of all the
efforts
i made
you know to
to get back in in good shape you had a
tough game against lanier and no one has
ever lost a game at the same field cup
and won the title what made you so
tenacious and determined to win it all
um well i knew i was playing well i was
not making many mistakes if any i mean
of course against rania he did make one
mistake but
um
i mean apart from the fact that i
confused the lines uh it was
impossible i was about to predict that
this was a mistake so i'm against fabian
i think i made one mistake at one point
but
it was just impossible to
to assess uh the mistake properly uh
from you my point of view so in general
i've been playing as good as i've ever
played and that gave me confidence
how do you contextualize this win versus
the first time
oh it's absolutely different
the first time it was
first of all i haven't won yet
but uh i mean you at least die for first
at least i first of course that
still comes very much for me but
it's not exactly the same of course and
uh
yeah last time i managed i mean i had to
win the last game to to win clear first
and uh
and i did but um yeah last time i was
really eager to prove my words basically
and
in general in the past few years i've
proven my worth
even though like this first half of the
year was i was playing
uncharacteristically bad
um
so it feels more like uh
redemption so
it is quite nice redemption great word
you i think you're back in the top 10 in
the world where you belong uh with this
performance
uh
talk to us about about
coming in last place
tied for last
in bucharest well you couldn't have
imagined that it would be this long haul
back and you come in second you win this
tournament for one and also come in
second place in the grand chess tour an
extra 50k yeah it feels absolutely great
i have to say um
of course in bucharest i had
extenuating circumstances for my players
i was feeling sick during basically the
world tournament
and this definitely didn't tell but uh
yeah my um my player has come a long way
since uh bucharest
uh will you be celebrating or waiting
eagerly to see the results of these
games
i'll be
chilling i mean
it's good
and to
not have to
suffer the whole day of course and
but
yeah i'll be
waiting to see to see what they do but
you know i'm not gonna stand every
second in front of the computer to
to see any mistake from
from my uh
colleagues so no i'll
i'll be cheating and whatever happens
happens from there i hear they have a
couple of nice pools at the chest houses
you might be able to chill by the pool
and relax congratulations on a fantastic
performance thank you maurice and our
congratulations to maxine very very nice
well done well done